hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 10th 2017 what's going on
how is you how's it going everybody and
you're doing good I apologize that the
podcast is late I apologize that it's
late I was flying back from San Antonio
I meant to do it yesterday but I was
doing a tour of San Antonio and the day
got away from me you know I was going
all around San Antonio I went out to
Jeff Wright drum shop I got some Mexican
food around the corner that was [ __ ]
delicious
I forget the name of that place but it's
gonna be on the video then he went down
to the river walk and over to the stupid
[ __ ] Alamo Jesus Christ just crawling
with [ __ ] tourists reenactors all
kinds of magnets and [ __ ] and I just was
like that you know every time I go to
San Antonio's like I'm gonna [ __ ] go
in there and I'm gonna read up on all
these guys who fought to the last guy
I'm gonna read up on every time I get
there there's like nine thousand people
in jean shorts there's a [ __ ] gift
shop and I just say forget it
I felt bad about it okay what do you
know what you're not patriotic that bill
you know then I ran to somebody from San
Antonio go you ever go into this thing
they go no we live here and I was like
oh I get it now I get it
the Alamo is your Times Square like
nobody in New York goes to Times Square
okay nobody in LA goes to [ __ ]
Disneyland or [ __ ] Universal unless
you have kids but I mean just as an
adult you're not gonna be now she's
gonna [ __ ] go there you know you
don't stand in line in your own [ __ ]
town
okay one of the advantages of it being
your own [ __ ] town
is you don't have to stand in line with
everybody else because you know all the
spots you know where to go you know
where not to go now when you're in San
Antonio where not to go is the [ __ ]
Alamo unless you're a goddamn tourist
then you go in there and then you're
gonna go over to the Riverwalk which is
actually for a touristy thing was very
nice that man-made River I got to tell
you something that's the first time I
walked
and I liked it I really enjoyed it there
was a bunch of people standing outside
getting a little hustle going on
trying to get you to go in and drink a
margarita I mean all kinds of wacky
people wearing hats people driving by on
the little gondolas you know it was like
you were in Venice but it was Texas
right there little slice of [ __ ]
Italy you know and then right around the
corner was the majestic big very ornate
the word only used to describe a theater
very ornate hey my buddy redid his
garage oh it's it's beautiful it's so
ornate nobody ever says that right they
call it a [ __ ] man cave okay so the
man caves for [ __ ] you know the
Twinkletoes there the Broadway stars are
these theaters and this thing had like I
mean had like [ __ ] houses and she
looks on Peter Pan stuff it was amazing
and evidently while I was on stage there
was a bat flying around then went past
me and aside the fact that it was a bat
like nobody even reacted they're so used
to bats down there evidently they they
kill all the [ __ ] mosquitoes are
enough of them you don't I mean so
people in San Antonio evidently cool
with bats I don't know but I had two
great shows the first show went awesome
and the second show was just [ __ ]
next level and I actually text my age
and I was like the hours ready and he
was like really and I'm like yes so
let's fill up the calendar they have
[ __ ] oh no it's not how I talked to my
agent I go let's fill up the flute you
know let's fill up the [ __ ] calendar
so his mission should he chooses to to
accept that he's gonna fill up my
calendar and then and I gave him the
list of the eight teams that I have left
that I need to go see all right so if
you're on this list I'll be doing a show
at some point within the next [ __ ]
year because I'm not gonna he's out in
the next year before my daughter starts
walking and talking and doing all that
stuff I got to knock this out so I need
the Toronto Raptors the Ottawa will play
in my Boston Bruins in the first round
of the playoffs congratulations to both
teams making the playoffs it's a big
deal playoffs oh wait no no wait are we
playing them I think we are playing them
which makes no [ __ ] sense to me
[ __ ] hockey if we like the eighth seat
should we play the Capitals shouldn't
the Capitals be rewarded that they won
their [ __ ] division rather than
having to play the [ __ ] Penguins and
then they knock one another out and all
we got to do is try to get past the
senators no disrespect but disrespect
intended no I'm just being honest all
right let's check this [ __ ] out right
now okay you know this isn't gonna work
you know it's nyeh you know I'm gonna be
on the run [ __ ] won the Boston
Celtics are a second seed they're a
[ __ ] second seed they're all right
hang on a second NHL playoff bracket all
right here we go and it failed NHL
[ __ ] playoff bracket all right yes
this is what the [ __ ] I want you gonna
make me click on it again I typed what I
wanted and then you're like is this what
you want yes this is this is what I want
all right
the Rangers versus of Canadians the
Bruins get the Senators I don't get it
Capitals get the Maple Leafs okay all
right all right all right I thought in a
cold there's a good one Columbus first
the Penguins that one Nashville
Predators made the playoffs playing the
Blackhawks Minnesota Wild versus the st.
Louis Blues and I'm Ducks versus the
Calgary Flames in the San Jose Sharks
versus Edmonton Oilers here we go
Brad Marshawn is back and all of that
[ __ ] so anyways yeah I got to get the
Toronto Raptors Ottawa Senators I gotta
get the Brooklyn Nets I've already seen
the New Jersey Nets but my rule is if
you get a new stadium I don't give a
[ __ ] I'll eventually see it but if you
move to a new city it's especially a
state you know then yeah I got to go
[ __ ] see you again all right I need
the Carolina Hurricanes Orlando Magic
Tampa Bay Buccaneers the Memphis
Grizzlies and the New Orleans pelicans
so there you go so I'm going to try to
get you know I probably do the Canadian
ones at the same trip and I'll try to do
the [ __ ] in Orlando Tampa at the same
time then I think I'm going to do a bus
trip to knock out those [ __ ] three
Carolina [ __ ] men
because in New Orleans I think that
that's what I'm gonna do and then I'll
be done and then what will you do bill
well you know what I'll do is I'll move
on to [ __ ] College alright cuz the
day I go out on the road and I don't
have something to [ __ ] look forward
to and I just sit in the goddamn hotel
waiting for the show that's it I'm gonna
dry up hear me dry so anyways I got
Boise coming up and I just got an email
from the theater VMA agent saying hey
we've been watching these videos seen
bill likes to play the drums what if we
rented a drum kit and put it in the
theater during the day and if Bill wants
to play during the day he can come in
and play for like an hour how [ __ ]
great is that it's the coolest thing
ever I made em up it might put that on
my [ __ ] rider
I don't give a [ __ ] how much it cost
because this is the thing they always
say hey we'll do that for you and then
they just you know they pay me less
money that's how it works now god damn
it this isn't in [ __ ] stereo I just
realized it wait a sec wait a second she
let me see something
there we go you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
that's not it how do I get this thing in
stereo you know this is just one of
these [ __ ] days isn't it isn't it's
just one of these days now I'm just
gonna push buttons what's going on there
it is now it's in stereo oh Jesus Christ
I thought there was something wrong with
the wire my fault well you had to suffer
for 7:53 I'll let ya I'll just say that
it isn't you know this you know
something you know what's great about it
it'll give you something to complain
about you know unless the great Andrew
chthamalus fixes the [ __ ] thing I
don't know
anyways plowing ahead here
so what else okay so I went down there
and I saw I saw a lot of San Antonio
this time you know like I said I had
great [ __ ] shows you know what it was
kidding who I I lost I completely lost
my train of thought because now I'm
[ __ ] mad at myself why didn't I think
to just [ __ ] push that button I
immediately thought it was the wire I'd
troubleshoot it I never knowingly lied
about the wire
alright so now I know what you guys are
thinking hey Bill you know you said that
you were gonna watch them all
turn ative sports this weekend you said
you were gonna watch the math the MotoGP
and [ __ ] Formula One well ol [ __ ]
Billy freckled-faced the fat did it no
glue heaven [ __ ] [ __ ] I did two out
of three
I watched the MotoGP you know what's
hilarious I didn't realize that there
was two undercard motorcycle races and
I've said they going like this [ __ ]
race is only twenty laps
what's going on here right the first one
was the GP three then or something -
moto three then the Moto - and then then
there was the last one so I kind of
fast-forward through the first two and
then I watched the whole I watched the
whole MotoGP the real [ __ ] one and
congratulations - I don't know how to
say this guy's name maverick finales you
know I saw that Marc Marc and bird
whatever his [ __ ] name is he was
cruising around and all of a sudden he
just didn't make this turn and he was
very upset with himself that's his name
Marc Menendez that's not Woody's that's
the guy who killed his [ __ ] didn't and
he killed his parents I don't know what
happened and then Valentino Rossi came
in second and both of them today seemed
very excited about that you don't I mean
they got some points they felt good
about themselves and I got to tell you
something that those [ __ ] guys and
you got to check out the MotoGP it's
unfuckable the amount of crashes that I
saw in all three of those races there
was one guy who's going through the turn
he started to accelerate in the back end
kind of kicked a little bit so he got
off it then he got back on it and the
[ __ ] the goddamn bike head I had a
seizure [ __ ] did a couple little s's
and then just like started flipping over
and then the guy of course he flies off
the damn thing it hits him in the back
of the head it amazes me that they get
back up again those suits they have are
incredible they got a little airbags in
them and [ __ ] but still they always end
up [ __ ] up their hands or their
ankles or something like that but this
guy kind of high-sided on it which is
basically you know if you're a novice
like me when they just sort of lay it
down and the bike starts sliding and you
just kind of you just touch the ground
and slide with the [ __ ] thing hi
sightings when it hits the ground and
you [ __ ] catapult
the top of it the high side of it and
that's when you get seems to me that's
when you get [ __ ] hurt it's
ridiculous they're going like 200 miles
an hour in something that you can just
fall off of but I enjoyed the race
immensely I enjoyed that race as much as
you guys why we didn't enjoy the first
seven minutes 53 seconds of [ __ ] no
stereo on this I and then I watched I
watched the Masters too and I could not
be happier for Sergio Garcia I mean I
just you know it's one of the things
about being at his level when you go
that long without winning is that gives
you ever give every mouth-breathing Haga
das eatin [ __ ] douche bag who never
achieved anything the right to walk up
to you and start telling you about how
you can't get it done your honor I mean
sitting there wearing a wife-beater with
your flabby grandmother [ __ ] arms you
know just givin this guy's [ __ ] when he
missed that one on 18 I was like oh god
oh boy here we go here we go shades of
Kenny Perry is this what we're gonna see
again and actually every year when I
watch the Masters you know I don't watch
it every year I shouldn't say that but
every time I watch it somebody always
folds in the back nine and I actually
get mad at the tournament I always end
up you know I was actually texting my I
was texting up court who did the live
final day of the Masters and I was just
like dude can somebody just win this
[ __ ] event does anybody ever just win
the Masters no one ever wins the Masters
somebody [ __ ] loses it every year and
you just have to watch somebody like a
buddy of mine tested me texted me tested
texted me and said if Sergio doesn't win
this playoff he said that punt will that
putt will haunt him it's like no it
won't it will but you know what's gonna
haunt him is every Cheesecake Factory
ting douchebag walking up to him you
know giving him [ __ ] right not realizing
that that missed putt is a [ __ ]
metaphor for the other person's entire
goddamn existence this guy's played in
over 70 something major so anyways just
like watching Phil Mickelson
way back in the day like Oh for was so
great to watch him get the monkey off
his back so congratulations to him
winning the most difficult activity
known to man playing the non sport that
is golf you know I still had to give it
[ __ ] right it's such a my know it's such
a doing it's so hard it's such it's
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] I get it I get it but
I would rather have to do that than face
a [ __ ] roided-up well he never got
convicted so car drug Rehman's right
Roger lemons right I wouldn't want that
guy thrown half a [ __ ] bat at me
you know just muttering explicative
as I walk up to the plate like I would
much rather have to try to sink a
[ __ ] three footer then some [ __ ]
roided-up maniac on the goddamn mound
who can't admit that his [ __ ]
career's over so he's got to go out and
take some [ __ ] horse tranquilizers
not saying that he did it and you know
what if he did god bless him god bless
him that he did I am by him so [ __ ] I
told you I'm Pro steroids dude I'm
[ __ ] pretty everybody should get on
him you know I want every [ __ ]
athlete on steroids okay and then the
doctors can look at you and see what the
side effects are and they can gradually
make them better and better and better
and better until it's like vaporized
weak you know you just have a cast air
ride missed in me with my fucked-up
shoulder you know what I mean I'll just
come in and just walk into the doctor's
office you know they'll put a [ __ ]
hot towel over my head like I have hay
fever and then they'll just have me
breathe in steroids I'll walk out I'll
have glutes again after 20 years is
sitting on my ass in planes and rental
cars my [ __ ] glutes will come back
they're just like non-existent I don't
know what happened I just [ __ ] like
you know like when you're gonna make
something you got to pound out like a
[ __ ] chicken breast yeah that's what
my [ __ ] ass is like after years of
being on a plane so I actually made my
way across to the gym when I was in San
Antonio to their sister property
sister property you mean the other hotel
[ __ ] weirdos anyways and I went in
there I did the elliptical for about 40
minutes and then I just did a [ __ ]
for me for me I did a savage [ __ ] leg
workout and now I I you know I know you
guys are all thinking well what did you
do bill alright this is what I did I add
the exercise ball I put it on the
[ __ ] wall between me and my back and
then I would just roll down with that
you know so I could keep my back nice
and straight
am i my weight on my heels pushing
through my heels to engage my veal
[ __ ] buttocks there what did i do i
did hip thrusts after that you know that
i did some calf raises then i did the
classic you know the things you sit down
will you do the front parts of your
quads and then the other one you stick
them in your funk and go the other way
you do the back part of your legs and
then i got on this squat machine i don't
like don't let you stand up on i like
the one that you sit down on i feel you
can go deeper you don't have to worry
about your [ __ ] back and and i did
that i did [ __ ] three sets all of
that [ __ ] and this morning my legs were
definitely killing me so that's a new
part of my workout okay that's what I'm
doing but I don't have all those leg
machines when I'm here you know what I
mean and my shoulders [ __ ] up so I'm
not putting a barbell on my back with a
bunch of [ __ ] weight okay I will just
I will choose to do more squats without
any weight because I am an old man but I
swear to God I swear to god man those
[ __ ] athletes matter they got to keep
taking steroids you know just like the
singer so you know a singer can't sing a
song what do they do give it a give her
a little bit of [ __ ] steroids right
in the throat give her throat deal right
there Fred what happens she [ __ ] she
goes out there and starts singing a song
she makes it simple and you know what in
the last the whole night long sorry and
then lastly for alternative sports I I
thought I'd take the [ __ ] Formula One
race in Shanghai China and I didn't
[ __ ] pisses me off so all I did was I
just watched the highlights so
congratulations to Lewis Hamilton him
and the the guy wanting Australia they
could you know they came in one and two
and now they just flipped so they're
tied with 43 points the [ __ ] his name
I should know his name he only won a
goddamn race right that's all right
Sebastian Vettel for the Ferrari team
they're tied at 43 and max Verstappen is
25th 25 points I'm sorry in third place
and [ __ ] Rikki Rockett is in fifth
place Kimi räikkönen now he's not the
guy called who's a guy called [ __ ]
Rikki Rockett Nico Rosberg is that it no
Nico Rosberg [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] know there's too many goddamn
sports going around my head now anyways
the playoffs and NHL stat we're playing
Ottawa I like her goddamn chances I
heard that defense is a little banged up
according to Joe bartnik on the puck off
podcast I'll be watching all of those
I'll be tweeting I don't be [ __ ]
Facebook and I won't be doing any of
that [ __ ] but maybe I will so anyways a
pretty good when I was on the road now
so he kind of bad you know I had that
Mexican food it was just [ __ ] you
know I used to you know I just always
make fun I and the Toros make it fun of
like Mexican food as far as like you
know the refried bring beans and the
rice that they put on the plate and I
was just like you know what this [ __ ] is
this is Mexico's version of coleslaw
you know what coleslaw like most people
don't take it seriously it's basically
it's a plate filler you know you got
your piece of meat you got your
vegetable and then they just throw that
[ __ ] they're just so the plate doesn't
look naked you know what I mean you oh
wow look at this big plate of food I got
no no no that's Mike more than 60% rice
and beans I didn't get it all right then
once understands now you mix all that
[ __ ] in together you grab one of those
little [ __ ] round pieces of bread
whatever the [ __ ] you call it you put it
on that you know a little bit of hot
sauce it's delicious you got a little
bean and rice [ __ ] a [ __ ] thing
there think I'm a jig sorry I'm white I
don't know I'll learn it I've only been
out in LA for ten years at some point I
learned it was that a tostada I know
what an auntie Lauda is I know what a
crispy taco is she said crispy or puffy
never had puffy before I always go
crispy you don't mean but the crispy
tacos it's it so it's only good in the
first bite because then the whole
[ __ ] thing falls apart the only mean
it's like an old person's hip you barely
touch it an old thing just cracks and it
doesn't work anymore so you kind of got
to go soft taco right
the flaccid taco all right I'm sorry
but then if you mix the beans and rice
in there is all I can say it was goddamn
delicious let me yeah let me do a little
bit advertising here a little ads here
for the for the for the week here what
am I doing here come on why won't you I
want this computer work right for now
form okay oh here we go our old friends
here first reading week old zip are you
hiring well are you do you know where to
post your job to find the best
candidates posting a chav in one place
isn't enough to find quality candidates
if you want to find the perfect hire if
you want that perfect person to walk
through that goddamn door you need to
post your job on all the top job sites
and now you can with zip recruiter com
you can post your job to 200 plus job
sites including social media networks
like the Facebook and the Twitter like
the Facebook and the Twitter all with
the single click find candidates in any
city or industry nationwide just post
once and watch your [ __ ] candidates
roll right into old zip code is easy to
use interface no juggling emails or
calls to your office quickly screen the
candidates ex-offender rate them get the
[ __ ] up and hire the right person fast
look at the rack no juggling emails or
calls to your office that already say
that find out today why olds it has been
used by Fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses and right now my listeners
can post on zip recruiters for free by
going to zip recruit at calm slash birth
at zip
Kirti calm / / one more time to try it
for free go to all zip dot-com / / sorry
the last one was creepy alright Dollar
Shave Club Duke buying a [ __ ] raises
a lot like buying a car to get a smooth
to get smooth luxury quality kid you
have to pay a huge [ __ ] price and
that means you're paying mostly for
splashy marketing and features features
you don't actually need switch to
dollarshaveclub.com it's the smarter
choice luxury quality at an economy
price tallest shape clubs razors are
amazing quality they got the shave tech
you need and none of the overpriced
gimmicks you don't have you seen the ad
for the razor's monopolies newest razor
thing it's got like 24 blade swivel
pivot Robo razor with the laser pointer
you know though if you don't need any of
that [ __ ] once they go and beyond two
blades it was stupid okay every year
they make a tiny change to the razor and
then the new blades don't fit the old
[ __ ] handle it's the Steve Jobs thing
the new phone doesn't fit the old
charger it's the same goddamn thing and
all the other ones they end up in the
ocean then they try to convince you it's
totally new and you need to spend even
more for this [ __ ] join the dollars
joint Dollar Shave Club and just be done
with all of it there's never been a
better time to give them a shot right
now you can get off your [ __ ] ass and
for the first month sign up you can get
any of their amazing razors for only a
buck including free shipping and after
that it's just a few bucks a month it's
fun kids there's no long term
commitments no hidden fees knows where's
this relationship going we need to
connect more none of that you're a [ __ ]
buddy with these people
you can cancel whenever you want get
your first month for for just a buck
buck at dollarshaveclub.com with those
we for free at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / alright
two more and there's this short just
hanging here m/v m/t watches Michael
Vincent Michael tango watches movement
watches start at just $95 at a
department store you look at it four to
five hundred bucks
Ruben figured out that by selling online
they were able to cut out the men
in retail mock up providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construction and styled minimalism over
1 million goddamn watches sold in over
160 countries but not including North
Korea you know why they couldn't find a
strap big enough to get around that
fatties wrist what do you say that
pork-belly call-to-action must read hey
easy easy [ __ ] relax I gonna read it
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to mV mt watches
dot-com / / this watch has a really
clean design seriously I've been getting
compliments ever since I put it on I'm
not wearing one I don't know what
they're talking about now is the time to
step up your game go to movement watches
dot-com / / join the movement once again
it's MV MT Mike Victor Mike tango
speaking of which I flew a helicopter
for the first time since October 31st of
last year and I'll tell you was a rough
one I was [ __ ] rusty I'll tell you
that story in a second right after our
old friends here stamps calm Oh stamps
calm come on shake the cult off hi
you've been all right I've used I use
stamps calm any time I'm selling my
posters you know I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure out how to use the scale on the
postage meter silk'n you okay stamp
saves you time and money what you can
use to grow your business I maybe just
sit there scratching your ass anything's
better than going down to the post
office you can mail a letter any package
using just your computer and your
printer and the mailman comes and picks
it up the mailman alright
not that lady he got to drive down and
[ __ ] give it to her avoid the hassle
of the post office man and mail
everything from the post from post cards
two envelopes two packages domestic or
international stamps calm will help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter right now you can enjoy
this you can join the stamp service with
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without long term commitments go
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage
for that stamps.com enter / one more
time stamps.com never go to the post
office again unless you're one of those
weirdos that collect stamps okay yeah I
flew for the first time I went up with
an instructor and holy [ __ ]
anybody out there flies helicopters I
mean geez
I missed the [ __ ] pad when I was
coming in I mean I missed it by probably
60 yards just coming in way too fast I
was like I got a guy settling with power
[ __ ] this I just kind of continued on
past it like you're supposed to came
back around the next time you know I
came up a little short
it took me about I don't know 26 goes
around till I'm starting to feel it
again and it was funny like my fourth
times I just flew the traffic pattern
down there at Long Beach and my fourth
time around I was turning to go downwind
and I just started laughing a my
instructor started laughing too cuz he
knew I was laughing it was just like
this is [ __ ] awesome
she's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] awesome and
it just totally relit the fire in me to
go do it and I'm gonna try and fly again
before the end of the month so if I can
just kind of fly like once every 10 days
or something well I'm getting a little
one going you know I would be very happy
with that it's such a was such an
accomplishment in my life to get my
pilot's license I would hate to just not
do it and forget how to do it it's so
much [ __ ] fun
and it's really safe you know what I
mean if you just do what they say the
way they maintain them I know everybody
always tries to freak out but you know
though he's freaking and always freaking
me out like it would be careful out
there
be careful oh yeah okay I was gonna fly
with a blindfold yeah but I get I get it
anyway so let's uh let's plow ahead here
oh yeah so I ended up you know what I
can't plow ahead here because I was
gonna start doing the reeds and I'm only
a twenty eight minutes so I need to run
my Yap a little bit longer so yeah I
think we flew the tab traffic pattern
for like just like a little over an hour
I got a 1.1 on the hob Smita and didn't
do any autos it was just all low
approach you know normal approach steep
approach that's
all I was doing and it was fun flying
the 22 which is my that's my favorite
one even though the 44 is cool you know
it's a nicer one I just thought the 22
is like driving an old sports car with
no power windows no power steering
[ __ ] drum brakes
I always just put that one it's just
like um whatever it's doing I'm actually
doing it I heard on some of those
high-end helicopters if you want to huh
if you want to hover you just push a
button and it just does it for you
that's the one you get when you get
older you know what I mean I don't want
to draw it on a dime all right you know
what I'm just gonna start reading these
[ __ ] I'm going to start doing the
reads here for the week oh by the way
what what's the deal with all the
haunted houses in San Antonio you know
it was the usual stuff as far as as far
as you know Texas goes Texas is the king
of the shiny four-door pickup truck
that's never seen a construction site or
off-road in Texas that's a four-door
sedan then I'll take it they got some
[ __ ] nice ones I saw a guy pull up
you know a Ford f-150 Ford or it's got
giant tires on this old [ __ ] guy big
white cowboy had big [ __ ] belt buckle
and white cowboy boots no it's just like
ah this is Chris you know as a tourist
it's like that's what the [ __ ] I wanted
to see now I can say went to Texas you
don't I mean I don't wanna see somebody
looking at their [ __ ] iPhone I can do
that out here alright update psycho from
yogurt shop video all right bill turns
out that nut job I don't even remember
this who was a costing the couple oh oh
oh that's right this goes back to like a
couple podcast ago where there was this
woman who was trashing these two people
for kissing in public saying that it was
sexual harassment and all of that type
of stuff and I kind of agreed with her
run on a level is I just I hate watching
people kiss in public you know I mean
give each other a quick Peck you know
going for one real one if you want to
but then just keep it moving you know
what I mean tellingly sit
that take you to the point where her
pussy's getting wet and your dick starts
standing up it's like what do you don't
get the [ __ ] out of here
it's gross all over each other I [ __ ]
can't stand it I don't like it at movies
you know if-- it's disgusting
anyways it's so here's an update for
this lady flipped out was yelling at
them and you know they're not gonna call
the cops I couldn't get through the
whole thing cuz she looked like she was
a little uh you know had some mental
issues going on something was going on
and she was extremely lonely or somebody
filled her up with Jesus I don't know
what happened anyways bill turns out
then that nutjob who was a costing the
couple at the yogurt shop is an amateur
porn actress yeah oh boy
now witnesses say that the guy only
kissed his girlfriend on the forehead no
lip service
oh all right my fault and it wasn't the
first time she's yelled at people in
public it took the internet like half a
day to get to the bottom of it Wow well
that's too bad that's too bad
you know what I mean you know it's weird
about watching porn as much as you watch
it you know nobody wants to do it no
that was not a [ __ ] job all right let
me read this here go to the page go to
the page that's what ice age all right
here we go is it gonna come up for me
viral video of meltdown over 40 how
exactly did they figure out who she was
how does the internet get to the bottom
of all of this stuff all right here we
go
recently a viral video video went viral
having a meltdown over a forehead kiss
yeah this all happened at a santa monica
restaurant goes so far to believe that
the women woman is something something
that seems screaming oh Jesus Christ
yeah come on man it's not enough it's
not enough she made an ass of herself we
gotta take it out on a [ __ ] know about
this person
felt bad for hope she turns her life
around all right update Great Barrier
Reef it's time for another update sounds
like your skepticism of the reports that
it ain't all that bad was warranted
all right the Great Barrier Reef yeah
this is more [ __ ] I'm gonna read about
[ __ ] people who've gone crazy doing
porn and I don't read about the [ __ ]
Great Barrier Reef dying what are you
guys doing to me
I got another [ __ ] 27 minutes to go
oh my god is just a holy [ __ ] okay Great
Barrier Reef at Terminal stage
scientists despair at latest coral
bleaching data Australia's politicians
has betrayed the reef and only the
people can save it I should read this
because maybe I don't know maybe they
can turn it around because there are
uplifting stories about nature out there
you know where certain species are
making a big comeback you know what I
mean
all right back-to-back severe bleaching
events have affected two-thirds of
Australia's Great Barrier Reef a new
aerial survey have found the founding
the findings have caused alarm among
scientists who say the proximity of the
2016 and 2017 bleaching event is
unprecedented for the reef and will give
damage coral little chance to recover
all right what site is this this is
called the Guardian now what is their
agenda yeah I mean you never know what
to [ __ ] believe here scientists with
the Australian Research Council centre
of excellence
Jesus Christ take it down a little bit
huh [ __ ] arrogant bastards for coral
reef studies last week compiled aerial
surveys of the world's largest living
structures
scouring bleaching at 800 individual
coral reefs across 8,000 kilometers the
results show the two consecutive mass
bleaching events have affected 1,500
kilometer stretch leaving only the reefs
southern third unscathed oh boy oh there
you go you know what the deal is we have
to go a significant portion of us have
to go you know maybe it's good that the
robots come are they gonna be electric
robots are they gonna require oil also
but you know something all these [ __ ]
electric cars you know when you go to
the split button that Tesla that giant
Tesla battery now what do they do with
that when you're done with the car what
happens to that battery I know that
constantly has updates does that also
include the battery can you make the
battery better let's look that up I bet
there's a bunch of [ __ ] oil companies
putting some [ __ ] out true or otherwise
about this Tesla car footprint okay
let's see the carbon footprint of Tesla
manufacturing Tesla's the left's liquid
cars aren't as green as you might think
the electric cars aren't green yet
nothing is green
nothing is green then Doug Stan at Doug
Stanhope had a great joke he said the
greenest thing you can do is kill
yourself and I would go further if he
didn't just say and then have yourself
buried in the topsoil so you [ __ ]
give it some nutrients actually we're
all so full of [ __ ] god knows what
McDonald's and [ __ ] you'd probably cause
the tree next to your body to die does
the Tesla Model S electric car pollute
more than an SUV this is the Green Car
report all right let's see let's see
whose can't no the Tesla is not about
being green that's about going 0 to 60
in 2.3 seconds does that supposedly
clean green Tesla Model S really pollute
more than a gas guzzling jeeps Grand
Cherokee sports utility vehicle that's
what one analyst has claimed now what I
love about this is everybody has a dog
in the fight obviously the oil guys
don't want you to switch over the
[ __ ] electrical [ __ ] and all the
electric people they are so convinced
that batteries you know didn't Michael
Jordan to a commercial a long time ago
but recycling your batteries didn't he
do that you know that's how I know about
it right cuz an athlete told me not to
do it but what about that giant battery
at the bottom of the Tesla what'd he do
with that thing what do you do with that
when it's done alright in an exhaustive
6500 word article on the financial
website seeking alpha analysts Nathan
Weis lays out a case model s that the
case model s actually okay okay we know
what he said he said it was worse an S
owner I was shocked for me I just felt
this is true
although the carbon emissions were not a
big factor in my decision bah-bah-bah
okay Weiss has been advising his clients
to short the stock of Tesla and it's
good that it uh alright not so fast
power plant emissions can't alright I'm
not reading all this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what this is this is just a media
war right now going on and I don't know
where the [ __ ] to get the facts and I'm
not gonna just look at the up the first
goddamn thing and read it I have no idea
you know but I can tell you this all
right I know that guy the head of Tesla
has like ridiculous security around him
because remember that guy who came up
with the car that could drive across the
country just on water and then he went
around and told people about it his last
words when he walked out of the diner
was they poisoned me and then he died
and then his car disappeared I know that
sounds crazy but that's a true [ __ ]
story
it's a true story according to the
Internet all right follow up girl who
gave weed ultimatum I love the follow
ups everybody this is like our own
little mini series here on the podcast
this is tremendous I'll give you that
guy's name - you guys can look it up you
guys let me know if you think this is
[ __ ] real enough all right water
power car inventor vanishes what is his
name what's his name what's the name of
the [ __ ] water guy yes Stanley Meyers
water fuel cell there you go
look that guy up go down that [ __ ]
rat help rabbit hole Emmy why he our I
think is how you spell it right Stanley
Stanley's are always [ __ ] honest
doctor one of my favorite promoters
around the country that's his first name
Stanley right he's [ __ ] Rain all
right follow up to the girl who gave me
the weed ultimatum all right for those
of you missed the podcast a couple times
ago there was this woman this guy was
dating you know he's always smoking weed
around her she had problems with alcohol
and [ __ ] and then one day I don't know
she cleaned up and she just lashed out
it and I said he needs to just totally
quit smoking weed or
you know it's either her of the wheat
alright so here we go it says your
brother bill on for three you responded
to my email about the ultimatum my
girlfriend gave me her vs. weed my
[ __ ] computer's gonna die hang on I
gotta hit pause I can't keep [ __ ]
yammerin expect you guys to listen to
this [ __ ] hold on alright I'm back I'm
back I'm powered here I'm powered up
here
all right on four three you responded to
my email about the ultimatum my
girlfriend gave me her vs. we either
choose her or the weed man
she has since admitted that she was
being a [ __ ] by giving me the ultimatum
and no longer cares if I smoke she has
since been smoking more weed than me and
two days after she gave me the ultimatum
the following happened yeah dude I don't
need to read this see this woman is
unstable she needs to get help and if I
was you I'd get out of this relationship
but I'll read it for the entertainment
value here she stumbled into our
apartment so drunk that she couldn't
stand she was accompanied by another man
Oh bonus there we go the guy she was
with happened to be the one guy that she
swore she'd never talked to again
because a couple months ago he sent her
a ten page email professing his love for
her and trying to convince her that I'm
an [ __ ] and she should be with them
up until that point they were friends
that hung out on occasion which I was
okay with Jesus but after he sent the
love letter which she read to me she
told me she would never speak to him
again why did she read this to you you
didn't need to hear all of that okay
anyways back to the cup a couple of days
ago we got in a fight and I said I was
going to leave because of the [ __ ]
weed ultimatum but instead she left
what anyways back to a couple days ago
so wait when did she stumble in this is
like a [ __ ] Tarantino movie two days
after she gave me all right so I guess
before this bull should happen you said
you were gonna leave due to the [ __ ]
weed ultimatum that were you telling me
but instead she left claiming she was
spending the night at her sister's and
said she went straight to this dudes
place got shit-faced drunk went to a bar
with him then came back to our apartment
both of them she did not expect me to be
home when she saw that I was there
he immediately walked out oh Jesus she
was so drunk she was unresponsible so
the fight didn't come until the next
morning when she claimed that the only
reason he walked in was probably because
he was just making sure she got home
safely no boy I told her that I'm done
and then I'm moving back to my home
state seeing as she's the only reason I
no longer live in my home state good
good move good move sir since this
incident she's been crying and begging
for me to stay and wants to get married
etc I get the [ __ ] out of here she
claims that she has no interest in him
and she was just mad at me and was under
the impression that I had already packed
my things and left and she just needed a
friend at the moment those are all lies
and this is the tip of the [ __ ]
iceberg sir that goes all the way down
to the [ __ ] ocean floor
personally I don't think I can forgive
her honor or trust her but I need to
make a decision and fast get the [ __ ]
out of there sir because I'm either
gonna tough this out and stay here oh
Jesus hoping this [ __ ] doesn't happen
again or I'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of
Dodge and move back home and start over
help me out brother should it should I
stay or should I go your thoughts
thanks and go [ __ ] my life now not [ __ ]
your life if you stay you're [ __ ]
your life to get out of there now that
you just heard what you wrote out loud
back by me reading it out loud which
probably made no sense do you realize
how insane that is how insane it would
be for you to do that I'm almost
thinking you know as much as she needs
to get her life together you need to
look at yourself as to why you would
stay with a person like this yeah you
need to get the [ __ ] out of there dude
all right
you still got your whole life ahead of
you all right and as far as like married
somebody you basically get one draft
pick all right because when you get
divorced your franchise gets cut in half
and then you start drafting in the later
rounds you know you're getting older and
[ __ ] this is your number-one draft pick
this is what you're gonna pick this
person with all the [ __ ] problems
that happen at the college level
I'm telling you get the [ __ ] out of it
right dude yeah I mean Jesus Christ if
you don't believe me go go ass tell
twenty strangers that [ __ ] story I
swear to god they're all gonna say the
same thing get the [ __ ] out of there go
on dr. Phil who do you need to get the
[ __ ] out of Dodge he'd say the same
thing actually he probably wouldn't
because she's a woman his audiences
female so he probably got well maybe if
you smoked a little less weed and she
tried to [ __ ] a little less other people
even y'all could find a middle ground
now all the way be like I inserted
myself into that situation all right
men going their own way you kidding all
right
this is a [ __ ] amazing food cake hey
yo Billy boy I was wondering if you were
secretly behind this movement this is
[ __ ] crazy
this right here is there's some movement
evidently down in Australia down in
allsey down in all is whatever the [ __ ]
they say I don't know if the [ __ ] they
say I've only been there a couple of
times
oh the plug came undone was there a
reason why they turn the plug into a
magnet you know back when it plugged in
it did much better I guess it's easier
to find you know it's got navigation
kind of and you can find the [ __ ]
hole but it won't stay in there all
right there's a growing movement of men
in Australia called men going their own
way I just paused for all the guys
listen to this with their girls so she
could have time to roll the rise and be
like oh all right mg t o W [ __ ] ow
it's an offshoot of the men's rights
movement but rather than getting stuck
in and tak stuck in and tackling issues
no rather than getting stuck tackling
issues these guys have vowed to stay
away from women stop dating and not have
children
Jesus essentially mgt o-w is a statement
about living your life rather than
trying to make a woman happy
sorry happy sorry screamed all my jokes
last night or being a slave to cultural
expectations 1sw member says this isn't
about a specific rule book more a
mindset although there are purists in
the movement who are the most extreme
and avoid women entirely there's a
growing number of men who've had enough
enough of the feminism and enough of
being told they have to work for a
greater good which doesn't actually
exist start looking into this mannose
fear and it's like going down a rabbit
hole this person says happiness here is
supposedly freedom and shunning
relationships is now sweeping through
the younger generations is it or is this
just a very interesting article okay Tom
15 from NSW north southwest whatever the
[ __ ] that is is what you call eggs and
what you would call the growing number
of teens going their own way Jesus kid
never even got off the ground he goes
it's probably not yeah it's probably
true but I got the feeling the women are
actually dangerous maybe the men around
me have just had bad experiences he
tells the news woman he said it's scary
being a teenage boy I'm not sure how it
all it's all meant to fit together in
the future says Tom last year my uncle
lost everything because his wife of 40
years decided she didn't love him
anymore
just like that she randomly got up and
left it got nasty and he lost everything
his house cars and loads of money
there's no way I'm ever getting married
well they I mean [ __ ] you saw a very
traumatic thing of course teenage boys
look at other males in their life to
gather some perspective I'm just gonna
read quotes cuz I'm hungry dollars my
older brother's 20 was dating a girl for
a few months she turned real nasty in
the break-up and made a string of
allegations to the police that made me
suspicious of women to my mother by
brother's a good guy okay
why should she be able to just say what
she wants accuse him of anything and
then get on with her life like that it
doesn't seem fair to me I'm not sure
what rights I have maybe none okay both
sexes okay it's crucial that we
encourage our children find a mentor a
teacher of some above above someone who
supports communicated that them yeah
about skills of getting a healthy
relationship that's exactly what I was
gonna say what are you just gonna walk
away from women you know you're never
gonna bang another one maybe just go on
tinder look you can get a lot done not
being a relationship male or female just
focus it on your [ __ ] career button
you know if you want to be alone that's
[ __ ] cool but to do it because of
fear reasons is wrong but you need to
learn how to do is set up your
relationship and how you set up a
relationship is you have to you don't
pretend to be something you're not and
just tell them what the [ __ ] you want
from day one when she's going like do
you watch sports all the time be like
yeah I love them love them you know I
like doing most when I do that like
drinking a beer and then going out
smoking a cigar that's what I do
hey sweetheart what do you do don't tell
me what you do and let's see if what you
do mixes what what what I do because if
we both start pretending oh my god you
changed no I didn't change I just I just
started being myself for the first time
around you I didn't mention that I was
into dogsleds yeah well I just figured
during the first three months I'd make
you fall in love with me and then I
would bring my 18 Huskies into the
[ __ ] house all right you're talking
about a guy who's made every [ __ ]
possible mistake that you can make in a
relationship I've [ __ ] up more goddamn
relationships with great women I got to
taste something okay you know III dated
some great women and I [ __ ] them all
up all right and it wasn't till I met my
now wife not saying I did make a bunch
of [ __ ] mistakes after that but I just
met somebody that I don't know I was in
that
part of my life or I could just be
alright that's what I do that what you
do yet I never you know that's the one
thing I am you only a few things I am
proud of with all the relationships I've
had women is I've never liked I never
judged them as far as like whatever the
[ __ ] they were into I didn't give a [ __ ]
you know whatever you want to do just
just [ __ ] do it cuz I just looked at
it like if I give you that sort of
freedom then you'll give it back to me
and if you don't then I'm [ __ ] out of
here and what are you gonna say what are
gonna say that's the thing that's Mike
you know my friends come over here Jesus
Christ fail you always [ __ ] cleaning
up the kitchen you [ __ ] doing all
this type of [ __ ] around the house it's
I can't exactly that's the genius I earn
a great living and then I come home and
I [ __ ] crush it so then when I want
to go out go see my buddy play drums
tonight what's my wife gonna say no why
cuz you have a daughter
ah right okay she's got the daughter
card now so what am I gonna do plus I
[ __ ] love my daughter so great coming
off there now that's the best it's the
greatest thing ever the greatest thing
ever she's not she slept with through
the night for the first time of course
the day I had to get up early you know
and fly out so I missed the last three
hours she I think she slept that she
slept from like 10:00 to like 7:00 in
the morning [ __ ] unbelievable and
she's such a cute happy chill kid I'm so
happy about that you know because I am a
[ __ ] lunatic and I she's not home
right now that's why I'm doing the
podcast a little late too so she's out
with their mother and that is my goal
you know I don't know if well I have
another one I have no idea but whatever
kid or kids that I end up having I want
them to be happy relaxed I want them to
feel like they can approach me they can
ask questions I am by no means gonna be
a pushover I'm not gonna buy him a bunch
of [ __ ]
I'm already against that buying kids
[ __ ] toys before they're like three
years old or two and a half is stupid
they don't even know what toys are okay
they want to go out of the kitchen they
want to play with pots and pans you know
they want to play with your shoes they
want to play with everything but toys
toys that
bore them okay you get him some pots and
pans it's over
they love them they like the noise they
like the handles they like making a
[ __ ] mess it's great but you know I'm
not gonna be that [ __ ] person by and
you know 78 [ __ ] iPads before my
daughter's pissed at me in the future
and she goes back and listens to this
episode and is now playing it to me
sometime in the future you know Jesus oh
they'll be a rough one
anyways uh let's plow ahead let's get
yes I would say like that whole like men
going their own way I don't know that's
silly why would you do that you're 15
years old you're in the prime of your
life you don't don't be in a
relationship just be that guy who
fingered bangs chicks on the weekends
you know and then on Monday when you go
to school and you're like hey you know
like we're gonna do that again yeah you
know if you want to hang out I mean I'm
kind of doing some and then when they
[ __ ] go like so what's she deal
you're just gonna finger me it's just
like what you didn't enjoy it yeah I
think I did something bad you know just
I just want to be in a relationship
right now I'm young you know and they
called it finger-banging
doo doo doo doo doo all right girlfriend
spiked my drink Jesus Christ
you know it's funny if I said that in
front of a crowd everyone would laugh
it's the other way around everybody
gasps what'd she do spike your drink and
[ __ ] take your wallet that's how a
woman rapes a man all right hey bill a
couple months ago I went to a party went
to a garden party to reminisce with my
old friends a couple months ago I was
Ricky Nelson everybody if you didn't
recognize it a couple months ago I went
to a party with a few friends among them
was the girl that would become my
current girlfriend I had a few drinks
but was shocked to see just how drunk
they got me I don't remember the entire
night because I was so drunk you know
some of these are so [ __ ]
over-the-top I just can't believe don't
even tell me then you ended up with this
person I'm supposed to believe this I
went to the bathroom twice because I
felt that was going to throw up today my
girlfriend confessed to
me that she and her friends had spiked
my beer with shots of vodka all right
that's not so bad that's some college
[ __ ] you didn't taste it she thought it
was a funny prank until I clearly
expressed how [ __ ] up that I was she
apologized and all that saying she never
wanted to hurt me but I'm thinking this
is breakup worthy most of my friends and
family agree I should leave this isn't
the only issue in our relationship and
I'm thinking red flags at this caliber
are too large to ignore should I walk
away well dude you only gave me one
piece of the puzzle there you know if
she was drunk and she was in a silly
mood with their friends and they [ __ ]
did that I don't know but like it seems
like there's a bunch of other [ __ ] that
she's doing and you already seemed
convinced that you should [ __ ] walk
so I don't know what the other stuff is
so I can't give you advice on that one
sir I don't have and that you know I'm a
hung jury on this one I need I need more
information I don't know what to tell
you so I don't know if that's the only
one that you were gonna tell me and
that's not a great way to start a
relationship it is kind of funny though
I don't know I'm kind of an alkie so in
a way that's my dream girl you know at
some point you also got to admit that
you know she did buy a couple of shots
that night didn't she
you just didn't know it all right I'm
taping a lot of [ __ ] on me TV for me TV
taping a couple episodes of what the
[ __ ] name of that show what's a this
show Valerie Bertinelli was in with the
redheaded lady and then the other chick
and then Schneider next door the [ __ ]
was the name of that show not the
apartment not the odd couple got three
chicks in a janitor what the [ __ ] was
the name of that shut up God SCH Snider
sitcom let's see what we got what do we
get one day at a time one day at a time
I taped a couple episodes of that and
then an episode of Alice I don't
remember how those [ __ ] theme songs
went do you guys remember those ones
stay in a day at a time
theme it's called this is it the [ __ ]
out of here
what happened to my memory see if I
remember this I have such a crush on
Valerie Bertinelli but the day was so
[ __ ] broke that's what all these
[ __ ] 76 were about they were just
[ __ ] broke-ass people I guess it was
reflecting the economy at the time you
know like Alice was like you know
divorced driving this piece of [ __ ] to
Phoenix
Ford LTD station wagon what is that that
cannot be the real [ __ ] Sun that was
[ __ ] horrible singing that's what
happens we let the star of the show sing
it did she sing that [ __ ] thing you
know what I can actually block out the
singing to listen to the old studio
musicians that's what I miss because
that was just some [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] laptop and the keyboard those
are all individual people playing all
those instruments got divorced got the
station wagon and I'm in a new
neighborhood I'm that kid who played
Tommy he was [ __ ] adorable and then
in between like season five in season
six he grew like three feet and that
includes his teeth all of a sudden he
had these [ __ ] horse teeth he was
[ __ ] gigantic he looked like he went
from [ __ ] being her kid to be in the
a walk-on for the Phoenix Suns anyways
that's the podcast for this for this
Monday I want to thank everybody that
came out to shows at the Majestic
Theatre on a Sunday night I know all you
guys had to go to work the next day I
had such a great time San Antonio is
great oh I didn't talk about I went to
the Spurs game went to this bar first
[ __ ] uh against the LA Clippers great
game [ __ ] amazing fans very very
knowledgeable of the game I got to see
their five championship trophies they
got him right out there where you can
see him took a picture and all that [ __ ]
was great and but I got to tell you
something if you want to win some free
[ __ ] go to a Spurs game I've never seen
so much free [ __ ] giving out in my life
first of all they had this coyote and a
mask and a
a guy in a coyote mascot costume in like
nineteen times during the game he stole
that the vendors cotton candy and they
would play the Benny Hill song Wayne and
the vendor would sort of mock chased him
around as the thing was [ __ ] throwing
free cotton candy all over the place
they did that like ten [ __ ] times
which made me immediately think like
they ordered too much cotton candy this
month it's going bad let's just get rid
of this [ __ ] so we don't have to throw
it out also look like you know like
we're good guys for giving it away
they had cookies coming down from the
ceiling in parachutes you know they
would just float down people jumping up
for [ __ ] cookies they dragged some
guy out of the [ __ ] crowd and put us
put a couch but you can recline in and
they put it at the foul line they're
like if you can sit down and you can
[ __ ] sink this foul shot we're gonna
give you this couch the next thing you
know I give you like you forget about
the game there's so much [ __ ] going on
I'm rooting for this [ __ ] couch
potato to win a new [ __ ] couch to
slowly die on you know shoots the first
one the next one rims out and then he
hits it never exactly freaking out he's
jumping up and down as man tits flopping
all over the place and then they just
dragged this leather porn couch off yeah
you [ __ ] what if you want it alright
and then you're looking up at the
scoreboard like oh wait a minute I'm
watching the [ __ ] Spurs they're
playing that the Clippers that's what's
happening here this is a critical part
of the game there's a timeout now I'm
watching awkward dad's dancing who's the
best awkward dad dancing other than that
it was [ __ ] great I really enjoyed it
and that was franchise number 118 that
I've seen I know I'm getting like the
Rain Man with this I got eight left and
until the next season you know when the
LA Chargers in the Vegas nights start
but I plan on knocking those guys out
early early I might even go to that
first charges game just for them having
the audacity the [ __ ] move on me you
know as of right now in this moment I've
seen every team [ __ ] west of the
Mississippi from [ __ ] ducks as far
south as San Antonio is far
North is Edmonton and these two [ __ ]
are gonna come along and [ __ ] the whole
thing up for me I will not tolerate that
I will avoid my family I will take a
trip and I will go see both of these
[ __ ] why don't take a trip to San Diego
I sound like a crazy person go [ __ ]
yourselves thank you for listening and
I'll check in on you on Thursday